i've thought
a lot about
elon's argument that we might be in a
simulation
no no there is a simulation it's cold
literature
and we just have to decide whether or
not to enter it
i'm
currently in the midst of
the later stages of of proof's great
allah and
proof's observation of
human relationships is perhaps more
meticulous than that of any other writer
and it's impossible not to find yourself
identifying with
marcel and his
obsessive jealous relationships
particularly with alberti
it's the simulation and you you decide i
think
as a
sentient being how far to
in your own life
reenact these more profound experiences
that others have written down one of my
earliest literary simulations was to
reenact jack kerouac's tripping on the
road when i was 17 culminating and
getting very wasted in the hanging
gardens of zochimilco not to be not to
be missed and
it hit me just just as i was reading
proof that that's really how to live a
rich life that one lives life but one
lives it
juxtaposing one's own experience
against the more refined experiences of
the great the great writers so it gives
me hope that my children do that a bit
[Laughter]
do you include the
the russian authors very much in the
canon
yes i don't read russian um
but i was
entirely obsessed with russian
literature as a school boy
i read my way through dostoevsky uh
tolstoy turganyev
i uh check off
i think um
of all of those writers
tolstoy had the biggest impact because
at the end of war and peace there's this
great essay on historical determinism
which i think was the reason i became a
historian
but i'm i'm really
temperamentally a kind of togenyev
person
uh
oddly enough
i i think if you if you haven't read
those novelists i mean you can't really
be a complete human being if you haven't
if you haven't read the brothers
karamazov you're not really
you're not grown up and so i think i
think in many ways those are the
greatest
the greatest novels raskolnikov's
nightmare at the end of crime and
punishment
in which he imagines
in his dream a world in which a terrible
virus spreads do you remember this
and this virus has the effect of making
every individual think
that what he believes is right
and
in this
self-righteousness
uh people fall on one another and commit
appalling violence
that's raskolnikov's nightmare and it's
a prophecy it's a terrible prophecy of
of russia's future
yeah it's uh
and coupled with that is probably the i
also like the french the existentialists
all that the the full spectrum and
germans harmon has said and just that
range of human thought has expressed the
literature's fascinating i really love
your idea that the simulation
like
one way to to live life is to kind of
explore these other worlds and borrow
from them yes
wisdom that you then just map onto your
own lives you almost like stitch
together your life with these kind of
pieces from literature the highly
educated person is constantly struck
by illusion
everything is an allusion to something
that one has read
and that
is the simulation that's what
the real metaverse is it's the imaginary
world that we enter when we read
empathize and then recognize in our
daily lives
some scrap of
the shared experience that literature
gives us
yeah i think i've
aspired to be the idiot from prince
mishkin from dostoevsky and in
aspiring to be that i have become
the idiot i feel at least in part
you